by anyone's measure
china's belt and road initiative is a
massive
project trillions have been spent on
infrastructure
linking china to the world by road rail
sea and pipelines reinvigorating the
ancient
trade routes from china through central
asia to europe
africa and the middle east to southeast
asia
and india an ambitious upgrade which is
now an ecosystem
in itself hello i'm hazlinda ahmed
welcome to the new trade superhighway as
we continue to navigate
china's belt and road initiative
[Music]
we begin this program here in mumbai
known as a gateway to india
a symbolic entry point of the world's
largest democracy
but not so welcoming to china's belt and
road initiative
two countries with massive economies
accounting for more than a third of the
global population
but with a long history of mistrust
well i think it's understandable that
india is nervous about having this giant
neighbor that's just growing
so quickly and it's frankly outpaced
india in a lot of ways so i understand
india is nervous about this doesn't want
china to be planning the asian
infrastructure
but there is potential for india to
benefit if china is financing
good infrastructure projects around the
region many of the countries which have
gone in for belt and road projects
sri lanka for example and some central
asian republics
run the real risk of getting into a debt
trap amongst india's immediate neighbors
pakistan maldives and sri lanka the
three countries which we think
in our assessment can become highly
indebted
they've always been concerned about
china because they share a border and a
contentious border a disputed border and
they've always been concerned about
pakistan
so if the question is should they be
concerned about bri
i think they'll be most concerned when
it's touching upon countries that border
them where they have
traditionally had their sphere of
influence so
whether it's a rail line to nepal
whether it's a port in bangladesh or a
port in sri lanka or cpec
yes they will absolutely be concerned
about it
at the heart of india's opposition is
the biggest single project of the belt
and road initiative
the china-pakistan economic corridor
which snakes its way from one of china's
westernmost cities
through the disputed territory of
kashmir all the way
to the arabian sea cpc so far to date
is probably the biggest single component
of bri
it's very important to pakistan china
has not overnight but in a relatively
short period of time
reduced for example the energy shortage
that pakistan has had the electricity
shortage so it's very important to
pakistan recipient it's also important
to china because pakistan has been an
ally of china for a very long time
it's a counter counterfoil to india and
it gives them access to the arabian sea
so
it also borders a sensitive area of
china which is xinjiang province so
it's important for both parties that
actually succeed if i'm a commercial
enterprise and i make an investment
which is not viable i take the hit and i
move on
as a government my concerns are not only
financial
i can for example in case of sri lanka i
have a 99 year lease on a port right now
which sits very close to india and which
sits right next to a major international
shipping lane
i am also investing a billion plus
dollars in gwadar a port in pakistan
which is also not likely to be
financially successful
so i can get these assets right now
which are commercial ports but which in
the long run can have
other uses as well we have already seen
in case of djibouti
which is which is debt ridden most of
which is owed to china
now put part of its territory for use by
chinese is a military base some of this
is definitely strategic
the corridor from china down through
pakistan
it's hard to see that this is very
economic you know
going over the himalayas to get from
china to pakistan that's really not very
practical
so that seems like a strategic move on
the chinese part
i can understand why india would worry
that it's being surrounded as china
builds that infrastructure in pakistan
if you put all of india's rail tracks
back to back they would
circle the globe one and a half times
eight
billion passengers a year that's the
official number
it's much more if you add all the people
who travel for free
across this vast nation here at mumbai's
hub during crush hour
seven thousand cram into trains made for
just
1700 the system is antiquated
in need of upgrade i see the mood in
india changing
you will have quite strong investment
from the aiib
which is investing for example in the
mumbai metro which is the town city
we are in is an example of cooperation
around india's infrastructure now you
don't have to call that the belt and
road initiative
that could have happened without the
belt and road initiative the the reason
why belton road has been so
enthusiastically taken up by many of
india's neighbors especially
sri lanka nepal and pakistan is partly a
failure on india's part
to deliver connectivity to its own
neighbours if you look at india state
with this
immediate neighbors with pakistan it's
obviously minimal because of historical
reasons
but india has also been unable to
develop any meaningful infrastructure
and connectivity with nepal
in the last several decades the similar
case exists in case of bangladesh
where we have very little connectivity
either in terms of energy or in terms of
good transport
and the same thing is true in case of
sri lanka as well
mumbai was one of the original stops
along the ancient silk road its port
remains the country's largest
accounting for almost half of all its
container traffic
it's also home to the indian navy's
western command
looking west across the arabian sea to
pakistan and the middle east
and to the east the riches of southeast
asia and
ultimately china
[Music]
so some of the defaults such as sri
lanka are not surprising at all
you look at the size of the economy you
look at the kind of investments that
have been made
and you also look at the individual
projects humber dota port gets a traffic
of i think one or two ships every week
so it's it's not surprising that the
project has gone down under
and i think something similar is likely
to happen in case of gwadar
which is again about a billion plus
dollars is being invested if you're a
recipient country
in bri doesn't matter where you are and
china comes along and you negotiate
um let's say appropriate terms for
whatever the project happens to be there
aren't a lot of other competitors
beating down your door
so this has been china's huge advantage
they bring not only the funding but also
the expertise to actually execute
and that is a very compelling package
for a recipient country
you but the recipients do have to be
careful of the financial terms
so from india to central asia that's
where we're traveling next
as we continue to navigate china's
belton road
initiative
one of the countries that stands to gain
most from china's belt and road
initiative
is kazakhstan where in the capital
astana
administrative hub of the world's
largest landlocked country
a country locked between china and
russia at the center of a balancing act
between geopolitics
and economic advancement
astana is an ultra modern city built in
the oil riches of what is by far
central asia's dominant economy
a city celebrating its 20th anniversary
and a birth date of the country's one
and only
president
no sultan nazarbayev has ruled
kazakhstan since independence from the
soviet union
in 1991. seen here opening astana's
international finance center
a bold move five years in the planning
to link
the region's capital markets much like
his country has embraced
its role as a key overland pivot of
china's belt and road initiative
the key agenda of the economic policy of
the government is the diversification of
the economic
diversification towards creation renew
sub sectors of our economy
in a different industrial dimension but
also the services sector and among these
we financial services so we want to be
the financial hub of the region we want
to help to religion to develop
the economies and i think in western
kazakhstan in a very good
track to deliver it we are naturally the
first country
that lies to the west of china as we go
towards europe
and we have built our own infrastructure
even before the
initiative was launched we have built
500 kilometers of railroads
to reconnect east and west of the
country so when the initiative was
launched
this infrastructure came in handy we
were prepared and we are now cooperating
with the chinese on implementing
numerous projects there is a
program uh to implement 51 projects
worth 28 billion dollars in kazakhstan
jointly with the chinese they are
relating to belton road
initiative but not exclusively so it's
it's a very wide-ranging economic
cooperation of course one of the
key benefits for us is that we're
transit country
and transit is a very good
way of making money and then doing
business
in our country for example we have
finalized the kazakhstan part
of western china western europe
superhighway which is about 3000
kilometers long
it costs us something like three million
us dollars and that one goes to the
russian border
another route is taking us to the
caspian sea
and to that end we have built a new port
in kurik
on the on the shores of the caspian sea
and that route takes us across the
caspian to azerbaijan
georgia and then from georgia to turkey
and from turkey to
mediterranean and further west and
yet another one is the
railroad that takes us from the caspian
from from macdow to
turkmenistan and iran and to the gulf so
we we have
diversified our transportation routes
and we have
provided for various alternatives
not only going north west but also going
south
on kazakhstan's border with china are
plans to build the world's
largest dry port built on the kazakhstan
not far from what is known as the
eurasian point of inaccessibility
that's the farthest point on earth from
an ocean
nearly everything that crosses into the
west
by rail from china passes through here
the chinese invested into that 50 50
with us so
we have a train now that can uh travel
from
yanyongang in the um east of china
to through china to horgos then through
kazakhstan
and to istanbul in about two weeks
and we want to want to decrease the um
um the the traffic time they did the
transit time
to about 12 10 days so this part of the
world used to be the heart of the silk
road
for centuries and centuries in the past
and right now
as we recreate the silk road in asphalt
and rail now in still kazakhstan again
is recovering its place as the key
crossroads in the heart of eurasia
give us a sense of the sectors that will
benefit in kazakhstan
when the maritime communication came in
it
stole away the show if you will now
gradually land communications are
taking hold the industries that stand to
benefit the most
are obviously construction processing
petrochemistry
the products of petrochemistry are
needed in road construction
but also agriculture and food processing
already
i can tell you that the volume of
container transportation across
kazakhstan from china to europe
grows twice in size every year for the
past
seven years and it will reach 2 million
containers by 2020
so kazakhstan stands to gain about five
billion dollars
in transit feed transit fees every year
just down the road from the port is what
kazakhstan and china
are calling an international free trade
zone
dual cities on either side of the border
a planned
strategic silk road city that for all
intents and purposes for now
lies in a no-man's land during the cold
war this whole area was a controlled
military zone
the two towers you see behind me
represent the borderline
i'm on the kazakh side the chinese side
is almost
fully developed but kazakhstan says it
has big plans
to catch up cargos is a gateway to the
chinese market so we
agreed between two governments china and
kazakhstan so we're going to develop
this special economic zone regime which
will help us
to develop the trade hub over there so
the idea is that in the soviet union
time probably it was bottleneck and now
we're going to
kind of ex increase the breakthrough
capacity for the goods coming
in both direction but
five years after it was first proposed
on the kazakh side at least
this project remains a work in progress
some people have said that kazakhstan
will be the buckle
of the belt but there are challenges
before that can happen
as i said we have built the
infrastructure we have also
worked very hard with our other
neighbors such as russia and belarus
to establish the eurasian economic union
we are prepared in terms of synchronized
uh customs tariffs and synchronized
synchronized
railroad tariffs so we have not only
built
hard infrastructure in those two
thousand and five hundred kilometers of
railroads but we have also created soft
infrastructure if you will removing
barriers for trade from kazakhstan
in central asia to south east asia
that's next as we continue to navigate
china's belt
and road initiative
[Music]
for the countries in asean china's
belton road initiative
offers massive opportunities where
infrastructure
is key to economic growth from indonesia
to the philippines
myanmar to laos malaysia to here in
thailand
projects worth hundreds of billions of
dollars are underway
to improve connectivity
if we can have the physical high
performance connectivity in place
then we can see that that would help
spur
activities in terms of commerce and
investment
this is one of the backbone
of medium-term economic outlook
for indonesia i'm sure starting next
year
the productivity gain from the
infrastructure being developed
will be start to kick in to us threat
our economic growth we are not
going into building airports and hoping
they will come
we are improving our airports because
they are already currently congested
we are improving our ports because they
are congested
we are improving our roadways it helps
us
achieve our build build build program
and second because
it promotes not only connectivity within
our country
but also outside of our country
like many of its neighbors thailand is
betting big on the belton road
investing tens of billions with the help
of china to turn its
eastern provinces into an economic
corridor
and billions more on projects like this
a high-speed rail from here in bangkok
all the way
to china
the mecca station will serve as
bangkok's rail hub for fast trains
heading north to china
through laos and south to singapore
through malaysia
although that part of the journey is now
in jeopardy
it will also link the country's three
main airports
to thailand's eastern economic corridor
the eec we have planned it to be
the catalyst so to speak of connectivity
not just in thailand but also with
other countries especially our
neighboring countries now china and
students all of us
so it's natural that the eec can
link up with the build and grow
initiative
you could practically see a corridor
running north
china south through thailand
and to to asia
all the way each country has to look at
their own interests
has to make sure that uh you know
whatever
loans they incur are are affordable
not only to this generation but to the
subsequent generations
the two loans that we have negotiated
the first one is for a dam it's a 62.5
million dollars and the second one is
for the development of
a municipal water project that's around
200 million dollars
we are currently negotiating a large
larger loan and this will be
approximately
2.8 billion us dollars and this will be
for a railway project
again improvement of a railway project
that is already
you know in in in bad rep in the state
of bad repair
we have set up actually in indonesia the
priority infrastructure projects and
based on that we identify which
project that we feel we can then propose
to to be to be included in the bir the
biggest challenge has seen that is
really the execution
out of the 50 at the moment we only were
able to utilize about nine
so we are still very far to go so while
the funding is there
there are also a number of requirements
that we have to follow
in order to get that are there risks of
unmanageable
costs oh i think there are definitely
many right
i think this is not just about uh berlin
road as you know
indonesia at the moment is in the reform
process
a lot of the infrastructure projects
that's happening right now
has issues such as regulatory issues you
know
licensing we have obviously manpower we
have
also um land acquisitions issue there's
a number of also local issues
i think that we also have to solve in
order for this to be
maximized another of the key routes for
china will be its corridor through
myanmar
and local issues there throw up all
kinds of questions
the country borders china india and
bangladesh
providing not only a channel to the
indian ocean
but also overland west to the indian
subcontinent
there are concerns over many aspects
large infrastructure projects would
incur a lot of indebtedness
and there's a lot of concern in this
government over
the the risk of over-indebting the
country and passing on that to the next
generation
and i think that's a positive con you
know thing to worry about
the fact that we're not just going all
out in building things not
without regards for our budget position
after years of strict military rule
myanmar's infrastructure is in urgent
need of development
making it a prime target for the belt
and road initiative
the other concern would be how the
construction of these projects will pass
on
in terms of technological know-how as
well as human resources
into the country unfortunately for many
years china has been supporting myanmar
but sometimes in ways where myanmar
people would feel that they haven't
really gained very much from it
so there you have it the views from
india central asia
and southeast asia on china's belden
road initiative
i'm haslinda ahman thanks for watching
[Music]
you